[Musique]
laurent dupin bonjour bonjour véronique
merci d'être sur le plateau de tv fil 78
pour ce vip qui vous est consacré vous
êtes yvelinoise vous êtes très active
justement dans les yvelines et vous êtes
ici pour une cause qui lui tient à coeur
c'est à dire que vous avez créé une
association qui s'appelle art
convergence et je voudrais d'abord qu'on
sache que vous êtes à la balle si vous
êtes vous travaillez dans quels domaines
à la base de travail dans l'édition dans
l'édition médical et surtout sur des
supports comme médias on fait des
applications des sites internet très
spécialisés de formation pour les
médecins d'accord dans le domaine grand
chose à voir avec avec l'objet de
l'association est alors votre
association elle s'appelle art
convergence on a dit on voit la fille la
fille d'une de vos expo dites-moi ce que
c'est la fiche du prochain prix vidéo en
fait c'est un peu particulier où il ya
tellement de choses à dire alors bon là
on il faut bien vivre avec une maladie
psychique
il faut bien vivre mais bien voilà c'est
exactement sommes finalement ça résume
assez bien le projet de l'association à
la petite marque qui au départ en fait
s'est créé en 2013 grâce à des médecins
qui ont participé à ce projet à des élus
des personnes qui travaillaient dans le
milieu de la profession médicale en tant
que journaliste est en fait l'idée ça a
été de permettre d'offrir en fait avec
des personnes qui trouvent qu'il
souffrait de troubles psychiques la
possibilité de travailler avec des
artistes professionnels et d'exploser
dans les mêmes conditions qu'un artiste
connu enfin en tout cas confirmés et a
concrètement comment ça se passe
concrètement on les accompagne par
groupe de 8 10
enfin on des artistes nine aventis prend
un groupe des 8 10 ans plusieurs
artistes se relaient en général ils sont
trois quatre ans 20 gr en fonction des
artistes bénéficiaires et de leur talent
on les accompagne sur une année à peu
près à raison d'une journée par semaine
jusqu'au jusqu'à l'exposition qui est
ensuite scénographié pour laquelle on
réalise des catalogues enfin tout ce qui
est d'avoir une exposition à la fin de
chaque année
voilà un peu pour montrer le travail qui
a été fait voilà vous avez comment
détecte que la personne un don
artistique ou une fois des capacités des
envies artistiques
ça c'est un aspect aussi qui est
intéressant c'est que ça nous permet
d'aller voir les centres de soins les
psychiatres n'ont pas cessé tout parce
que des élèves les chercher on va les
chercher en fait on fait on lance des
appels à projets auprès des
des soignants en fait en psychiatrie
c'est à dire la règle est exactement où
art thérapeute n'ont pas forcément non
sens où les artères à peu de travail
quelques fois dans des centres de soins
mais nous on travaille pas directement
des amis vous à l'extérieur nous était
l'extérieur principalement on a
quelquefois des projets qui se sont
faits en intra ce qui s'appelle ans dans
l'hôpital mais ça c'était un peu
particulier un corps est chaud c'est
d'ailleurs là nous avons deux affiches
des expositions vous avez déjà réalisé
sont les deux dernières explosions à la
secte malheur celle-là dix mois nature
naturelle et elle a été présentée à
l'école des beaux-arts de versailles
dans la galerie au mois de septembre
cette année pendant 10 jours
d'accord mais combien d'artistes alors
voilà elle est issue du travail de huit
artistes bénéficiaires qui encadraient
donc par bertrand à la petite qui est un
ancien directeur de l'école des
beaux-arts
deux autres artistes laurent scouten et
stéphanie biville qui sont des artistes
confirmait pas tout à fait professionnel
mais bénévoles des bénévoles libellis
maintenant voilà pendant l'année une
fois par semaine exactement
c'est alors liste l'autre gêne un peu
particulier justement parce que là en
l'occurrence ce sont des artistes qu'on
a qui étaient considérés comme
professionnels cirque on a rémunéré pour
ce projet oui et c'est un projet qu'on a
monté entièrement avec le conseil
départemental et l'hôpital jean martin
charcot
on a en fait instituer un atelier dans
l'hôpital dans une friche de l'hôpital
pour construire des personnages que vous
voyez sur le sur la fiche qui sont ces
personnages en papier mâché qu'ils font
à peu près de deux mètres cinquante
trois mètres de haut qui reprennent le
tableau de l'escamoteur de jérôme bosch
d'accord il a en fait on s'est accroché
en fait
hôtel de l'esc amateurs à jérôme bosch
pour pouvoir créer cet explosif
vous avez combien de bénéficiaires pour
l'instant on a un peu plus de trente
bénéficier vous avez un lieu pour les
faire travailler
on a un lieu qui nous est prêtée à
versailles chantiers lundi
oui et sinon on est mobile c'est à dire
en fait on peut monter des ateliers un
peu partout en fonction des prêteurs et
je vais vous avez un projet vous avez
plein de projets alors c'est un peu
compliqué parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
de temps un prix de vidéos
alors on en apprenait cette deuxième
édition du prix vidéo d'un prix qu'avec
des dotations qui va être remis dans un
musée ou dans un lieu assez prestigieux
à paris
donc les vidéastes sans les
bénéficiaires de noront vers lens n'ont
pas forcément on a décidé d'ouvrir le
prix à tous on a réalisé déjà plusieurs
fois des vidéos et mouvements du compte
de l'impact de la vidéo sur le public
et l'idée c'est qu'avec des très courts
métrages les gens les professionnels de
la vidéo du cinéma des beaux-arts août
puisse parler la maladie psychique avec
un regard qui soit en connaissance
enfin le plus possible en connaissance
de cause donc effectivement ils peuvent
travailler avec des bénéficiaires ou
s'il est d'accord je comprends bon ben
alors à nouveau projet qui vous tient
plus à coeur en ce moment à l'intérieur
de l'association c'est l'artothèque
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une artothèque en
demande c'est une sorte de bibliothèque
d'oeuvre c'est à dire maintenant
l'association existe depuis quatre ans
on a réalisé à peu près 6 expo six
expositions et la plupart de ces oeuvres
sont souvent en souffrance à peu oublié
et en tout cas pas toujours bien
préservés et l'idée de l'artothèque
c'est de les remettre en lumière est de
permettre à des institutions de faire
une sélection via notre site internet et
de les exposer avec la mise en avant des
artistes qui les ont réalisés d'accord
donc en fait l'idée c'est de faire une
exposition itinérante
oui des petits morceaux de l'exposition
comme nombre d'oeuvres il était mon
plein zhou et puis avec une durée
peut-être plus long qu'une exposition ça
qu'on pourrait imaginer que vous faites
une sélection de dix dessins pour du
très grand bureau qui vous et qui vous
sont confiées pendant six mois voire un
an après c'est renouvelable
oui c'est très bien ça c'est un appel à
ces un appel à trouver un lieu qui
puisse aider ces oeuvres qui ne
s'apprend pas énormément de place et
qu'on puisse trouver quelqu'un qui gère
le fonctionnement de l'artothèque mais
ça ça pourrait être ça serait fait en
lien avec l'association d'accord va
coûter rochebonne on vous souhaite bonne
chance
pardon et bravo pour ce que vous faites
et puis vivement la prochaine exposition
en attendant on va retrouver alix qui
est un peintre qui bénéficient de cette
association et on va faire sa
connaissance
merci laurence et véronique bonjour alix
bonjour merci d'être sur le plateau tv
nous avoir rejoints
vous êtes ici parce que vous êtes
évinois vous êtes peintre et vous êtes
bénéficiaire de cette association par
convergence dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure
j'avoue nous recevoir c'est un plaisir
alors je crois savoir que vous avez
toujours été artiste finalement vous
avez toujours été attiré par le monde de
l'art visuel
j'ai activement jeune j'ai commencé à
faire des graffitis dans le métro et
pour attirer le
le regard des passagers est vrai que ça
me fait ça m'a apporté beaucoup
d'adrénaline beaucoup de plaisir de
plaisir sur le moment et c'était de
l'art urbain
donc vous vous exprimiez légalement des
graphistes ou et je faisais des graves
dans le métro principal c'était ça après
vous avez eu votre bac vous avez fait
une école d'art vous avez fait quoi
j'ai fait 3e satrape et ensuite j'ai
enchaîné sur une école de réalisation et
de création du visuel à aubervilliers
l'hectare et à troisième vous étiez
branchée qu'elle sait que traduction de
vieux amis accord donc on n'était pas
encore dans la peinture
non j'ai pas encore tout à fait dans la
peinture mais ça m'a toujours accompagné
ça va d'accord un bordé oui fur et à
mesure de mes études en parallèle avec
poésie visuelle et ont fait de la
peinture depuis combien de temps va
faire 7 8 ans que ça
on parle plus de graffitis 28 ans que ça
déménage que je travaille tous les jours
que kaka lui je m'y attèle activités
d'accor et comment vous avez rencontré
cette association art convergence alors
à convergence est pas venu à moi comme
ça en fait il ya un art thérapeute j'ai
rencontré un art thérapeute dans un
contexte un peu particulier qui
m'a permis de connaître la convergence
je signale juste pardon je vous plains
les knicks mais c'est que nous avons
vous oeuvre qui passe pendant que nous
parlons et on y reviendra après depuis
13h donc un art thérapeute de vous a
accompagné vers cette association
we are convergence de là de là est né un
projet le projet qui aboutit sur
l'exposition aux ondes vie de la reine
elizabeth à versailles le musée
exactement du jardin de la reine
elizabeth à vers madame elisabeth à
l'orangerie mais voilà vous avez si je
peux me permettre
et vous avez donc exposé cette série de
tableaux que nous avons là alors est ce
que vous voulez nous parler de votre
travail c'est quel matériau déjà écouté
la sq ont assez des pastels sèche et du
crayon fusain ou mixte effectivement sur
quel support
là se retrouvent des papiers d'accord et
celle qu'on avait avant j'aimerais bien
qu'on puisse les regards mois voilà
alors temps des portraits la fin peut
plus évoluer ce sont là j'ai voulu
mettre en
dans cette phase de transition j'ai
voulu mettre en relief le les émotions
tout ce qui brille à nous tous qui
bouillonne qui étaient en lien avec les
deux cas ces personnes que j'ai dessiné
que à savoir qu'ils sont des personnes
que je connais qui reste son départ très
sexy très bons jeunes est un peu plus
d'obstruer la nous avons bianca on a
besoin cas et dans une autre
karine maintes rumeurs d'accord est ce
que vous faites des autoportraits oui
aussi
oui oui mais j'aime beaucoup le modèle
vivant j'aime c'est ce qui vous parle le
plus mais effectivement pour revenir au
modèle vivant et pour pour
pour en parler j'ai
j'ai connu aussi eu la chance par l'âge
par l'incitation à convergence en vue de
participer aux cours du soir deux des
beaux-arts de l'école des beaux arts de
versailles
d'accord vous avez une formation modèle
vivant grâce à ça et vous avez donc
exposés aussi comme on le disait de
valeur l'exposition nature qui a eu lieu
en septembre dernier et celle aussi de
j'ai participé à cette de jérôme bosch
aussi voilà
et enfin j'ai l'exposé aussi à l'île de
ré dans notre lieu une grâce à des
artistes une team qui font parti de la
convergence comme gaël germany vous
épaule qui vous qui m'ont orienté qui
m'ont épaulé soutenu où il ya des
moments où on a besoin d'un regard
bienveillant encadré oui c'est sûr ouais
et de regards de professionnelles et
professionnels en plus
oui d'accord vous avez des expos prévu
là bientôt dans les yvelines ailleurs m
par ailleurs j'y pense un petit peu oui
sur des lieux un peu particulier jeu
genre jours la cité du cinéma jeu là je
sais pas si ça va être sympa durant mais
c'est un projet en l1
je veux mettre au point en riz et en ce
moment vous êtes à la halle saint pierre
alors alors oui c'est ça qui nous
interpellent et va je suis bénéficiaire
de cette chance qui m'a qui m'a été
donnée
gg il ya beaucoup d'artistes je voudrais
être exposées à la torture ou de soutien
de certains lieux où il ya beaucoup de
passages avaient été sélectionnés et oui
c'est à paris et c'est à paris en bas de
la butte montmartre semaine d'habitants
et ses avoirs
maintenant c'est au mois d'avril et
jusqu'au bout d'image s'est prolongée au
mois de mai oui ok alix perdu beaucoup
beau tableau j'ai continué et donnez
nous des nouvelles et bien avec grand
plaisir et xi a bientôt corps
enfin
[Musique]